well i would say quickly that in the
midterm election i had i had great
success we wound up after the election
in 1978 with a majority of 19 in the
Senate and a majority of 119 in the
house so we had a very good success with
that but I think that what is likely to
happen in next two years I hope is for
President Obama to be much more firm in
letting his specific views be known and
then adhering to his commitments through
thick or thin I think in this last two
years he's been faced with a totally
irresponsible Republican Party that have
given him on major issues sometimes 0
votes in a house in the house and in the
US Senate and I think he's tried maybe
too much to try to get a few of those
Republican votes which is not proved to
be impossible in the days when I was
president I had superb support from the
republican party in the House and Senate
and that gave me a chance to have a very
good success in my batting average with
the Congress so just stick to his guns
of be firm let the American people know
what what he wants quite without
equivocation and without doubt and don't
back down i'm sure those are the things
he's going to do in the next two years